[Musique]
donc nous sommes sa conversation
aujourd'hui avec marie-jo cj cali
survivants du génocide rwandais et alain
labonté qui sont invités et animateur
des balades aux bonnes moeurs d'en
parler respectivement donc bonjour comme
un talent et bourg on se fait pas bien
mais bonjour merci d'avoir accepté de
parler avec moi aujourd'hui pour radio
canada international donc je commencerai
par allait aller et moi on se connaît
bien
pour toutes sortes de raisons on a pris
deux buts souvient encore qu'en
travaillant semble donc aller pour
commencer j'aimerais que tous nous
raconte pourquoi faire un balado sur la
mort je trouve ça très intéressant je
pense que parfois on a l'impression que
le la mort c'est quelque chose dont on
parle pas beaucoup mais dont il faut pas
parler donc intervenus qu'il fait peur
tout seul donc bien capitalisées qu'il
ya trois ans pour cette vie d'annie et
son équipe ont mis sur pied l'événement
le salon de la mort à montréal et
c'était un franc succès parce que
effectivement y'a pas il n'existe pas de
lieu où on peut échanger discuter par
apparemment et c'est très très vaste
le champ de possibilités parce qu'on
peut parler du deuil animalier du deuil
jeunesse
comment faire un testament bref les
thèmes sont pratiquement infinies et à
cause de la pandémie paix condition
physiquement on pouvait pas faire d'
événement donc pour céder son équipe
on imaginait justement faire un balado
pour maintenir séduction là avec le
public qui les suivent sur les réseaux
sociaux un peu partout et on m'a demandé
si j'accepterais de quang ninh sauvé la
douleur parce que se termineront à la
mort je peux dire qu'il m'a accompagné
depuis ma tendre enfance en ce sens que
j'ai perdu malheureusement beaucoup de
gens alentour de moins et
personnellement j'ai accompagné cette
personne en phase terminale
donc je fais ce qu'il en est de pouvoir
tenir la main de quelqu'un qui va nous
quitter
donc ça m'a vraiment séduit cette
proposition là et à partir de là on se
fait un canevas de d'entretien qu'on
souhaitait faire
et parmi ces entretiens là on a trouvé
la perle rare maurizio gucci cali qui
pour moi c'est important de pouvoir
parler à quelqu'un qui avait sur
l'itunes génocide parce que je trouve
qu'à l'intérieur du génocide
il ya beaucoup de thèmes exploités que
ce soit de vivre au quotidien avec la
mort mais deux vivent avec la peur de
mourir et aussi à un moment de rêver de
mourir aussi
donc je ne sais pas finir de mettre
d'accord avec moi mais comme diverses
façons de le voir sont en fort que c'est
très risqué parce que quand tu dis en
plus cela la pandémie nous a apporté une
autre dimension de la mode
je parlais tout à l'heure de tenir la
main lors de la mort donc la pandémie ça
change complètement la donne
donc si on passe à l'expérience
justement à cette éviter parce que tout
à l'heure on pourrait revenir aussi vite
et que vous savez je dois aussi à lait
pour cette balade ou ses ballades aulas
mais j'aimerais aller donc au au cas
particulier des marie jo cj cali de
cette perle dont une part est tout à
leur mère et je sais vous êtes nous et
nous et non pardon à au rwanda et bébé
ici au québec depuis 1998 comme moi la
même année que moi je suis arrivé à
montréal la même année oui cette
commande ici survivante du génocide
commis contre les tutsi au rwanda vous
savez un docteur en sciences de
l'éducation à l'université du québec à
montréal entre autres
vous êtes très impliqué dans des
organismes communautaires et vous
souhaite aussi vice présidente de
l'association des parents et amis des
victimes
du génocide contre les tutsi au rwanda
donc je le disais tout à l'heure
d'entrer dieu pourquoi parler de la mort
mais pourquoi parler pourquoi c'est
important diriez vous de parler du
génocide du rwanda encore aujourd'hui
après toutes ces années
en fait merci de me permettre de parler
de ça et je ne sais c'est dur le crime
des crimes donc d'un crime
j'ai des films un grand nombre de gens
qui dans des conditions inimaginables
dans l'extrême souffrance et puis on se
rend compte que on pense tout d'un coup
que quand un crime comme sa place
d'humanité a appris comme après la
première guerre mondiale comme après
l'ère la shoah
c'est peut-être plus jamais ça mais qui
est étonnant c'est que ça se reproduit
en voir l'ue doivent se répète encore
c'est quand même extraordinaire les
esprits humains de kitty qui n'apprend
pas de la souffrance autant on est
accrochée à la vie donc on fait tout
pour bien vivre pour attirer la villa
bonnes conditions de nos enfants de les
gouvernements font tout leur possible
pour assurer les mêmes conditions de vie
aux citoyens ou garder aujourd'hui le
gouvernement se démène pour trouver la
solution pour endiguer la pandémie
mais qu'est ce qui se passe et pourquoi
des crimes comme ça le crime de génocide
qu'on voit revenir parce que le génocide
et je le redis piste ça a été prouvé
c'est pas quelque chose de spontané
c'est pas que des gens qui sont fâchés
contre d'autres personnes
sinon ça peut pas se réalise à peut pas
avoir lieu
donc ça se prépare et pis
c'est tout le monde le sait que ça se
prépare
démarre par un discours à la
discrimination par les autres n'osent
autres quand son discours s'établit il
faut allumer solide
il faut trouver les moyens d'arrêter
seppi je le dis souvent il n'y a pas de
de petits crimes
c'est comme un ce qu'on appelle les
petits crimes des petits discours de
discrimination
c'est comme une bombe à retardement a
fait je voulais vous poser la question
justement par rapport à la compréhension
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
arrivé au rwanda j'ai l'impression
parfois que en effet comme vous dites on
oublie on oublie rapidement on oublie
les passifs et on essaie de continuer
notre vie et les pays comme vous dites
sont tellement aux prises avec toutes
sortes de choses qui arrivent au jour le
jour qu'on a tendance à oublier le passé
qu'on a tendance à oublier les moments
horribles que l'histoire humaine nous a
donné finalement donc quelle
compréhension diriez-vous que
aujourd'hui on les canadiens les
québécois de ce qui est arrivé au rwanda
ce moment là mais je pense que c'est
c'est vraiment bien documenté
aujourd'hui il ya des films qui ont été
réalisés des livres et y ont été écrits
de documenter et qui ont été faits mais
on dirait que c'est loin c'est loin
derrière et puis ça donne
tant qu'on commence à oublier un peu ça
donne une piscine a créé aux personnes
qui veulent que ça s'oublie alors les
personnes qui veulent que ça s'oublie on
en était là dedans c est y aller oui
mais pour un sourire sauf que
marie-josée de vie l'importance d'en
parler pour moi justement s'était fait
en dans la discussion qu'on a eue une
marge aux émois sur le malade doit à un
moment donné tu fais référence
ou 11 septembre les tours jumelles ou
les gens d'ici ont été complètement
scotché par la situation mais un peu
avant moi je me souviens du rwanda
justement parce que les coups de
machette je peux pas concevoir que qui
est des gens côté d'une autre personne
qui se fassent massacrer de l'assaut des
femmes qui sont violées
parachuté dans un fossé n'importe quoi
mais on en parle les prétentions donc
j'ai l'impression que quand celles aux
côtés de l'océan
c'est comme ça ne concernait ni plus ni
moins mais en fait la douleur humaine
reste la douleur venant et c'est pour ça
que contre l'importance d'en parler
photo me dis que ces choses là arrivent
il faut être capable dé voir venir
justement puis de déraciner tous toute
cette méchanceté là mais malheureusement
l'histoire se répète
on le voit en chine actuellement dans
d'autres endroits mais c'est pour ça que
ce thème le moi il est important pour
moi qu'on en parle et me réjouis parce
qu'on n'a pas va jamais assez il faut
surtout aussi que de nouvelles
générations sachent ce qui s'est passé
oui c'est parce que nos enfants risquent
des rites de sa nécessaire
oui c'est jamais loin il hérite de ça
mais aussi c'est un devoir envers le les
victimes
on leur doit sans en manita n'a pas été
là pour les sauver
alors que pour le cas de tous si durant
là c'était vraiment un direct je le
disais c'est bien connu il ya même il ya
des expatriés qui des européens des
américains canadiens qui était au rwanda
donc c'est fait c'est pas m
parti très loin temps c'est très très
récent
non c'est un paraissait comme c'était un
hommage aux victimes qui on n'a pas pu
le sauver au moins conserver leur
mémoire unique ont comparé des deux
comme il faut comme des êtres des
victimes mais qui qu'ils ont créé
comme ça ils n'avaient rien fait une opa
mérité ça allait le témoignage de ma
religion c'est évidemment c'est un des
témoignages imagine un peu je ne connais
pas les eaux et toutes les autres
personnes que vous savez invités à
participer à ce bal à dos là mais celui
ci est particulier mais sa guide un peu
le laisser change tout le temps que vous
voulez donner à se balader n'est ce pas
le tout à fait en même temps d'antenne
de la mort comme je disais j'ai beaucoup
dax possible qu'on parle d'eux comme
l'accompagnement de jean france terminal
bon oui c'est que quelqu'un eut une
maladie qui dans un lieu excellent la
compagnie
parce que dans le cas de marie josée moi
je ne sais pas car un grand nombre de
gens qui viendront écouter se baladent
au c'est que je trouve que on peut faire
des parallèles avec l'actualité dans
l'addiction
on a eu marre jouer moi dans le palazzo
avaient tous a dit moi ça m'a beaucoup
touché
quand elle parle d'une centaine de
personnes de sa famille qui ont été
tuées dont on n'a jamais retrouvé les
corps donc on en parle souvent ainsi un
des gens qui sont enlevés les jeunes qui
disparaissent qu'on ne retrouve pas la
douleur que les parents ont de vivre
avec le fait de ne pas savoir où leurs
enfants dès 3 4 58 ans est défendu et on
aimerait mieux savoir qu'ils sont morts
et qui sont atteints en droit au même
stade où google books on sait qu'il ne
souffre plus bon tout ça mais quand
cette boucle là ne peut pas être fait
on vit avec 130 soit vis scaling disent
ils émergent aux expliqué il ya deux ans
quand son père est décédé que les
retourner au rwanda
au moment de mettre son parent terre
elle s'est sentie bien
donc ce fait drôle d'entendre ça hors
contexte de mes mots 219 quelqu'un
en étant elle met en terre laissant
personne qu'elle avait personnellement
bon on dénie combien de fois les indices
ici on peut pas faire de funérailles
mais si les gens savaient à quel point
c'est difficile d'avoir des thunes vie
comme marie-josé d'études et qu'elle vit
encore donc sauf d'un enseignement de
pouvoir écouter ses histoires là c'est
la famille d'andré comprendre davantage
sur nos vies exactement parce que
justement une des choses intéressantes
aussi dans ce que je vois de la
programmation que vous savez préparer
pour se balader celle que ça ça nous
permet de nous ancrer sur le québec sur
le canada d'aujourd'hui une certaine
manière
donc ma région c'est le travail que vous
faites ici
j'imagine que c'est ce type de
discussion que vous avez eue avec alain
ou encore aujourd'hui avec nous c'est
vraiment tard partie finalement du
processus de guérison du processus de
deuil
et ça fait aussi partie du travail que
vous vous êtes donné comme
responsabilité d'une certaine manière
mais tout à fait en fait la chose là bas
la chose qui m'intéresse le plus le
cessez de me sentir responsable de
quelqu'un ou de quelque chose
la première fois c'est quand j'ai
retrouvé mon père excusez moi j'appelle
comme le bois vert bon double influent
permet noël eux après le génocide
moi je me dis je savais que j'avais plus
personne j'étais dans un autre univers
que je peux pas décrire je sais pas
comment gt gt comme j'appartenais au
morne pour moi j'étais morte mais j'ai
appris que mon père un mois plus tard on
m'a appris que mon père était remplie
un jour décrit dans le livre s'cusez moi
pis quand j'allais retrouver je n'ai pas
reconnu il était j'étais presque morte
en fait tous là mon père léger on était
grand vanille on aimait énormément
j'étais fils unique
et puis j'étais pour moi mon père
s'était félicité donc à jour j et quand
je les ai vus j'ai eu la colère et
l'énergie la tuque moi je pense que je
pouvait soulever une maison vous aimez
rejeté hors de moi j'ai pris mon télé
dit c'est comme ça que tu devenu peut
enrager que le vit plus à 1000 enfants
peut-on par enfant devienne comme ça
mais c'était comme mélanger ça soit lui
qui survivent à ses enfants
pour moi c'était l'injustice la plus
totale mais le trouver dans cet état ça
m'a mis hors de moi alors j'ai dit papa
quand j'étais petit mon père le tenait
par la main et on était sur le monde là
on était dans un autre notre bulle qui
sont mal gérées tenus par m
jeudi le départ parce tu mens
on y arrive et on fait ça ça ne rame
ça nous ramène au titre du livre que
vous savez que si on n'oublie jamais
rien tant que vous gardez tout ça hein
vous l'amenez vous l'avez même été
capable ça et même été capable d'aller
le le vivent avec votre père ce
sentiment là de nous lira jamais rien
non à l'unc j'aimerais que tu perds un
peu de désordre invité brièvement aurait
peut-être dû rebondir leur nom nous
expliquer rapidement
et puis ensuite on va devoir se laisser
en fait le premier balade où je tenais a
invité le journaliste alain crevet radio
lorsque je trouve qu alain crevier avec
son le travail qu'il a fait pendant des
années dans l'animation c'est mon regard
je trouvais que c'était parfait pour
parler que de notre garde sur la mort de
évolué avec le temps et dans se balade
ou là on parle de ces rencontres est
justement de comment il voit aujourd'hui
la mort beaucoup plus paisiblement
autrefois donc je pense c'est une belle
entrée en matière on a parlé
l'artiste marc seguin sous le thème
quand la mort s'invite dans la création
parce qu'un jour un petit ami lui a
demandé d'intégrer les cendres de sa
mère dans un tableau donc c'est
intéressant aussi comme démarche parce
que enfin fois un tableau la même façon
on a parlé à marc gilbert qui ce que
pleurs d'un front uni verrier sadredinne
pour les soins palliatifs et elle est
aussi présidente bénévole de
l'association des maisons de soins
palliatifs y en a 35 au québec en tout
on a parlé lui qui ont pour le deuil à
nîmes a dit josée masson le 2e journée
d'ailleurs josé c'est elle qui a animé
les funeral les deux petits québécois en
afrique a retenti qui ont été rares et
il est mort dans un boisé l'été dernier
donc josé la ressource parfaite pour
parler de de sa lane médicale à mourir
bientôt on va rencontrer
un jeune homme de 87 donc c'est ça pour
moi ce sont des rencontres extra au
réceptionniste que lui en parle de la
mort puis on à cornes de grande valeur à
la vie tout à fait je vous remercie
beaucoup
je vous remercie beaucoup mais on
revient faire sans son salut aussi
[Rires]
mérigeau c'est jj cale y ait vraiment
j'apprécie beaucoup que vous ayez pris
le temps de nous parler aujourd'hui dédé
de partager ça avec nous vous êtes
auteur et vice présidente de
l'association des parents et amis des
victimes du génocide contre les tutsi du
rwanda vous s'est établi à montréal
comment dire depuis 1998 et puis vous
êtes docteur ben on n'oublie jamais rien
vous partager l'histoire justement de
votre vie avant pendant et après le
génocide
donc merci beaucoup et aller labonté
vous êtes auteur attaché de presse et
collaborateurs de tous le médias du
québec
[Rires]
vous animez avec foussat dit banni
j'espère la prononcer comme il faut
fondatrice du salon de la mort et vous
c'était à vous anime et avec elle le
premier balade aux québécois sur la mer
la fin de vie et le day 1 meur d'en
parler donc merci beaucoup à vous tous
merci marie jo c'est au revoir
[Musique]